the ancient philosophers Aristotle
Diogenes Cicero Seneca and many others
all of them are fairly well known for
their works but as fancy is all of that
philosophizing was how did they actually
earn a living
how did an ancient philosopher pay the
bills well there are many answers and
circumstances were often individual but
there were several common ways that
philosophers made their living and
shockingly they were largely determined
by the philosophers own beliefs
the first way that philosophers could
make a living was by giving lessons and
instructions it wasn't just philosophy
that would be taught though rhetoric and
other topics like mathematics were also
included the hope or at least the sales
pitch was that philosophers would teach
their students to be virtuous competent
leaders who would run their family's
estates competently this way of earning
a living was often criticized by other
philosophers in selling knowledge was
seen as immoral the second way was
simple they'd beg you see many
philosophers weren't very wealthy would
often take to the streets begging for
food or money the most famous example of
this is of course Diogenes who was
homeless and even briefly lived in a jar
and he would often berate people on the
streets until they paid him he and other
philosophers were often given
accommodation and food in the houses of
wealthy friends who wanted to hear what
they had to say and the third way they
made money was perhaps the most common
they'd find a wealthy patron now this
could take several forms sometimes a
wealthy benefactor would leave a very
large sum of money to a philosopher they
like the work of another way is
demonstrated by the philosopher
Epictetus
he wrote at the time he approached a
potential patron and goaded him into
becoming his supporter he asked why he
would entrust his body to a doctor his
horses to an avenue but not his soul and
virtuous well-being to a philosopher a
fair point perhaps but it ended with
epictetus getting punched in the face
and no patron he became his teacher
instead way number four was to become an
on hand philosopher Aristotle for
instance was a personal advisor to
Alexander the Great who had be kept
uncool for whenever the King had a
question and Seneca acted as a political
advisor to emperor Nero these were often
very lucrative positions but were also
quite dangerous since monarchs weren't
the most easy of patrons and the fifth
way was that they already had jobs and
would philosophize on the side Cicero
for example was a lawyer a Roman senator
and a consul and his philosophy was
often tied to public service whereas
Marcus Aurelius made his living by you
know being the Emperor
so to summarize it shouldn't surprise
you that in the days of subsistence
farming thinking for a living wasn't
really a viable well-paid career for
most it
largely down to the patronage of the
wealthy that ancient philosophers could
spend as much time philosophizing as
they did so how did ancient philosophers
make their money some had jobs some
begged for scraps and many were kept by
the wealthy I hope you enjoyed this
episode and a special thanks to my
patrons James Bissonnette the pastry
section Danny Maloney Marvin Castle
Kelly moneymaker Rob Waterhouse John
bisko's moe James Castaneda Aaron the
whites Jordan long way Marcus Arsena
Gustav Swan Jerry Lambton John Bailey
calling Castleman Rashid Ali spinning
three plates filled oink oink
Maggie Pats Kowski David Silverman Izzy
Lexi Schwinn Robert Wetzel Skye
Chappelle Spencer Lightfoot and Winston
K word